hey guys welcome back to a brand new
video we're back on a foreigner guy
Thank You Ubisoft for sponsoring this
video as always guys thank you so much
but today like I said we're back on
foreign we're gonna be talking about the
new in-game event which was actually
shown at e3 it's the new in-game event
shadows of the heat soak area that
starts today on June 10th is the time
I'm making this and it goes all the way
till June 27 so you have about 17 days
to get all the possible loot and with
that look of a special customize options
for a limited time within this in-game
event like effects ornaments weapons the
whole spiel everything like that and
even some stuff that you can't loop but
you have to buy like masks outfits and
stuff like that
Oh III foreigner also announced that a
spectator mode will be coming to the
game in 2019 so that's going to be super
exciting but today's video we're gonna
be talking about how to get all of that
loot the fastest and what we can do to
basically maximize the amount of stuff
that we can get as quick as we can
before this event goes so I was always
like the VP do enjoy subscribe if I knew
I covered the informational side a
foreigner that being the balance changes
the hero updates the patch notes and the
leaks so if I want to be kept up today
with everything happening within the
world of foreigner and never miss out on
an update definitely stay subscribe to
the channel and with that let's get
started so as I stated before there's a
lot of new things coming within this
event there's gonna be effects there's
gonna be weapons there's gonna be
ornaments
there's masks outfits and stuff like
that there's a lot of things within this
event sadly we weren't actually able to
be shown what those images are what the
weapons are what the effects are but
basically all the effects the ornaments
and the weapons and stuff like that our
end the battle outfits are going to be
lootable you cannot loot the mask outfit
you must purchase that and if you don't
want to even grind you can of course buy
the big huge bundle for your character
it's gonna be about 30,000 steel and
every time that you get a new item it
slowly decreases in price because the
Ubisoft does not want you to pay double
for the same thing yeah like I said
we're gonna be talking about how to get
this stuff the fastest before this event
ends and I gotta say right away that
arcade is the number one option if you
don't have arcade stick around to the
end of this video I'll explain a path
without using arcade but basically but
yeah basically arcade is going to be the
number one option for everything that
has to do with loot you can finish this
in a very short amount of time and can
get 4 to 5 items really quickly I happen
to get two effects and I think three
emblems the first time I ran through it
now of course the quest is going to be
changing weekly but as at the time I'm
making this this is the current quest
that is out and it's really not that
hard either I managed to clear it with
glad argue
one of the worst characters in the game
at this moment so you should really have
no problem the first one is a standard
one big one fight with Nobu she just
block and parry as usual she's not too
hard in the second one it's against a
Highlander and you cannot parry his
attacks so try to get somebody with a
nice and easy unblockable to counter
them I've tried with JJ but of course
that's with his heavy finishers and that
was very very hard to pull off because
the Highlander would crush encounter my
heavies so that's really not the case
anymore you know that's why I use
gladiator he has a very easy zone attack
that you can press it's two buttons very
simple instead of doing an entire combo
to do it and I managed to get through
the Highlander with gladiator the next
one is just a simple fight versus PK and
conquer you can fight these guys one on
one or two on one whatever you happen to
do I like to fight the conch immediately
since he's close by and let the
Peacekeeper come to me both of them are
super simple so this shouldn't be really
too big of an issue and the last one
seems pretty difficult but where JJ is
located on the map you could basically
allege every single one of them and of
course the shaman has three bars of
health so basically two heavy attacks
and she's gone so this is a very simple
final quest of of this would be a lot
harder than it seemed see as I said that
shouldn't be too hard i7 [ __ ] yeah but
as I said that really shouldn't be too
hard I sadly haven't gotten any new
weapons to drop from arcade but that
could just be dumb luck or there is no
apparently no weapons available in
arcade let me know in the comments I'm
pretty sure I just got really unlucky
with my loot and stuff like that but I
just like to know just to confirm but
sadly for you none arcade owners most
game modes are actually going to be
working just fine it's really just
simple grinding I enjoy the the newest
game mode simply because it's the
fastest but the problem is that it's
time-based and the shorter the ER game
is the less of a chance you're gonna get
more loot so if you have a very long
game like breach you're gonna be most
likely getting some larger quantities in
terms of three to four items but like I
said arcade can take you maybe eight
minutes and I got four to five really
quickly and that's wait smaller than a
breach game or a Dominion game but yeah
I would recommend the new game mode but
I would personally suggest that you do
player versus player if you do player
versus AI you're gonna get the game done
in basically two minutes and I did this
game mode three times back to back in
two minutes flat and I wasn't even able
to get any of the new gear I got
actually no drops at all ma not even
like anything I just got XP and some
minor steel so I really just recommend
do your
favorite game mode if it happens to be
elimination or Dominion go for that but
if you do have arcade definitely take a
advantage of arcade what you can and
honestly as I'm probably talking I'm
pretty sure the game probably just ended
or is very close it just shows how
really quickly you can finish this event
but the blog I said the problem is that
you're not gonna get too much loot since
it's time-based yeah let me know in the
comments below if you guys have any
better ideas than arcade I still think
arcade is the number one thing to get
all the loop for in the game but for you
now in arcade goers like I said just to
sum it up you really just have to play
any of your favorite game modes I like I
said I'm not going to be doing P Vai I
feel like if you do Dominion in player
versus AI that would be better cuz that
is a lot faster than just doing regular
PvP but in terms of the new event game
mode I would stick away from facing off
against AI players cuz then you probably
won't get much loot anyway yeah guys
that's gonna be the end of the beta
hopefully you guys did enjoy it like I
talked about in my last video they
didn't show what what the effects or the
weapons are so I'm going to hopefully
try to get a video on that soon unless
they happen to show it in an upcoming
dev stream but I'm gonna try to grind my
ass off to get it for you guys it's
gonna be very difficult but if I can if
I'm able to do it then I will definitely
try to post the video as quick as I can
yeah but like to be if you do enjoy
subscribe for new I covered the
informational site a foreigner that
being developed and is the hero updates
the patch notes and the leaks so we want
to be kept up to date with everything
happening from the world of foreigner
and never miss out on an update
definitely stay subscribe to the channel
once again thank you B cell for
sponsoring this video as I said we have
the spectator mode coming that which is
what they announced at e3 as well as the
in-game event the shadow of the heat so
carry with tons of lootable
customization options there's just so
much loot to go run and it's actually
kind of exciting that we get a lot of
loot to play around with and grind for
ba guys it's gonna be the end of the
video peace out
have a great rest du day and enjoy the
event
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]